hello rejects Greg here John here
headshot trailer - we had a lot of
requests coming today that because his
trailer dropped and I really loved the
first trailer that I saw by John he
really dug it - we are big fans of the
raid films I didn't know this is a
earlier today but the guys who played
baseball Batman and a hammer girl in the
raid - are actually in this film as well
I think Julie Estelle is one of them
like D main characters in this film I
think he plays a Rama's wife Uwe
yeo-hwa Scott ayahuasca wise EQ Weiss
and now we couldn't find trailers with a
with the subtitles available so we're
gonna have to watch this without
subtitles getting the triggers only a
minute and a half and we know the plot
Jason Bourne washes ashore
yes memory yes one of those stories
where past comes back to haunt him this
past he probably forgot about are you
joining in the middle of me talking yeah
man
no well glad you own up to it admirable
thanks man you know honesty it's very
that's very respective screenplay
infinity she'll love their films I think
so vocal Oklahoma be sad job huh
Ian Khama bisa dressing stick a tan
tanga do mnemonic vomiting go
Papa come will be scientist order
[Music]
a pion kamalakanta hospital
Ishmael rod becomes Bernardo oh we
better put some [ __ ] up
ah
Oh
[Music]
whoa whoa
[Music]
Wow jeepers whenever those guys do knife
fights man those just look like the most
nasty
I hate nice stuff like not any more than
a gun shop yeah yeah well cuz you just
know you're really ripping vital things
apart and I think most of us have been
cut by a knife like a little bit at
least like a little incision every once
in a while we had a needle or something
yeah so we know what it's like to have
our skin cut you're like even a kitchen
not just like a regular kitchen just
flub feels terrible sighs I can't
imagine all your [ __ ] like blue yeah it
looks like real when it's happening
you're like you can think about a blow
you're like oh you know hole can seal
back up but if you're ripping things
apart like you know those are limbs
you're never gonna use right again and I
know you mentioned this um when we did
our first trailer review for this I just
can't help but being an American I'm
gonna naturally compare this to the
Bourne Identity in some ways just
because like it looks like he's a former
hitman or something you know maybe not
part of like the government but it looks
like he worked with like criminals a
violent yeah living yeah I imagine yeah
like a some kind of criminal pass
otherwise you would it's such a strong
set of skills yeah all these bad guys
coming out really into this an
enthusiast go to a lot of fight
tournaments but I want to see a little
bit more capitalize on though that we're
not really getting in the trailers is
the love relationship he has formed here
cuz this looks like this woman is
someone who was part of his past and you
know was like I'm way for him in the
hospital and I'm curious to see how that
plays out with like those does she know
his past is she like trying to shield
him from his past like oh it's a good
thing he doesn't remember but then [ __ ]
starts to haunt them like I really want
to see how those dynamics play out
because I felt in this trailer we did
get more hints at their love story more
than the other trailer mm-hm
yeah definitely I mean I mean there
there's some nice little notes in there
like when they're both being on kind of
sleeping together in the hospital room
like you get this sense for the early
hug sure yeah oh
such a rough hug yeah right I want to
see what happens to their relationship
when the [ __ ] goes down yeah as it has
like the before in the after but what's
the mid its Julie Estelle I think yeah
she's only played Hammer girl and she's
playing the spouse or girlfriend wife I
don't know I'm the doctor no she looks
like she's his lover I mean they have
that hugging moment and they're at the
beach she photographs and yeah really
personal doctor it says like a young
doctor or something like that's in the
description oh yeah that's right okay
but it but then with the plot
description to describe it as a young
nurse nursing him back to health so
maybe she fell in love with him while he
was recovering his boss one of those
situations an intimate moment either way
maybe I mean Julia still kicked ass and
Ray - I would love to see her kick ass
in this film as well
it'd be cool they spot side by side
finds a nurse as a balsam said Marcia
yeah yeah she she's only started
doctoring in the later part of her life
she grew up assassin and instead of
taking life now she wants to nurse it
back to him we keep talking about how
cool the visuals look in it and the tone
and style like from two trailers I mean
these directors are known to do like
rather you know what's the word for it
kind of like awesome yeah there's a
certain kind of like menacing tone that
gets under your skin in their films and
I'm interested to see them incorporate
that a little because I thought we got
more of that in this trailer than we did
the last one the last one was more like
ray I know they didn't do the raid but
it was more raid reminiscent of the the
cool action and [ __ ] yeah had a much
more of a haunting tone to it with like
images of badassery in there yeah the
the two different for the trailers play
with - two different trailers play with
two different senses of scope I feel
like we know that they do like really
intense action like their action isn't
fun yeah yeah it's like it is but it
isn't because it's response causes
craziest [ __ ] but it's also like
cringe-worthy part of the interest in
seeing this for me is to see like what
the distinct tone they bring to this one
is because grant is like it's it's a
different directing team than as did the
raid even so like you know there's
connective tissue
curious to see what the new shade is yes
both the raid films are very different
you know yeah totally and they all have
this kind of gritty action style so I'm
curious to see what these two guys do
with that yeah guys headshot um I can't
find an official release date in the US
if you guys can comment it below of an
OB in California would love to know so
we can be there opening nights of review
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject John is a social
media manager of two things the Facebook
sites of bloom house and real rejects
and I want to give a shout out to
ayahuasca no the drug not not mmm-hmm of
the actor shout-out to ayahuasca you
have really helped me find certain
things about myself go to you every
three months I'm telling you the things
I learn usually a lot of purging of all
a lot of vomiting and diarrhea you know
it should happen you don't know a lot
about yourself in your clutch you learn
a lot of you lose some weight you really
cleanse yourself that's how I stay thin
and sexy totally all that all this is
true